叫做网易大龙虾是吧
叫做lowest AI
那四个框架呢其实它们都是存在共性的
特别是其他三个框架都是基于这个
open cloud这个思想来衍生的
那首先我要提出一个问题啊
大家会觉得open CD这个产品
这个产品或者这个开源技术
是一个比较新的东西吗
是一个比较新的技术吗
有同学还提到了KIMI老师吧
特别多啊
其实还有一些
那我因为个人时间的关系呢
也没有
也没有完整的时间去对比市面上全部的
那我就挑了几个典型
首先以大家一定要理解啊
就是open cloud这个产品啊
到底是不是一个新的技术
是不是一个新的东西
最近大家看到社区里面这个open CD点的这个star
数量数量甚至超过了超过了LINUX对吧
超过了像前端领域最大的react等等这些框架
Ok
那么为什么这样的一个框架
能够能够产生这么大的一个技术影响力
能够产生这么大的一个爆发式的增长呢
其实这里面证明了一个问题啊
就是可能全世界七八十%的人啊
对这个技术这一块他很向往
但是呢他理解又不是很透彻对吧
所以可能会很多人觉得像open cloud这样的产品啊
就是一个非常有突破性的一个东西
那实际上我们往前追溯一下
在去年还是前年啊
其实OpenAI就推出了
像computer use等等这样的一些技术
我们听名字也知道computer use是什么意思啊
电脑使用对吧
其实一开始啊
这些大模型公司早就已经想到了
如何去让大模型来操作自己的个人电脑
早就在做这个事情了
minus呢其实比minus还早啊
在minus之前
minus刚出来的时候
我也不觉得他是一个新的技术
在最开始之前
很多公司已经开始尝试做这个computer use了
甚至在应该就在2月份
现在3月份吧
在2月份啊
这个ENTROPIC呢他收购了一家公司
这家公司呢是专门做客户端智能体的
那他们做的客户端智能体
跟open cloud等等这样的一些客户端智能能体
有什么区别呢
其实他们想达到的目标是一样的
大家最终的目标都是
能够让一个智能体去接管你的电脑
帮你做很多很多的事情对吧
那他们的目标是一样的
但是实现途径会不太一样
像open cloud等等这些产品呢
他们是主要的基于AI大模型
就是我们熟知的这个LLM语言模型
甚至有可能加上这个多模态的模型来实现对吧
但是像AEROBI收购的这些公司呢
这家公司呢它是基于计算机视觉
计算机视觉呢跟语言大模型呢是两个不同的
AI领域
它基于这个呃计算机视觉
当然也要结合一些大模型的技术啊
然后从底层呢去突破这个电脑的一个控制权
当然殊途同归
我们以后的也会看到
这两种不同的形态的智能体啊
到底哪个更好
哪个更坏对吧
所以这不是一个新鲜的技术
但是呢它是一个不错的产品
是一个不错的工程技术
它是旧的
是已经存在的
但是工程化思想
应用思想
产品思想以及技术思路
是我们可以参考和借鉴的
特别是在现在的这个web coding的时代
大家都有能力去突破自己的技术边界
去开发出自己的产品对吧
所以我们需要知道什么呢
我们只需要知道这些东西怎么来设计的
这个工程怎么来落地
那么你其实也有能力
自己去做自己的这个智能体
好在这里我又要提问一个问题啊
就是为什么我们还要去做自己的智能体呢
既然市面上这些大厂
比如说阿里的这个这个Q的是吧
还有我们网易的这个lobster
还有其他的一些公司啊
他们其实都在做这种智能体
那我们为什么还要做自己的智能体呢
其实这个呢就跟现在的钉钉
飞书以及钉钉
飞书以及他们平台上的这些服务商一样
如果说你了解过像企业微信
像钉钉的这个服务商或者飞书的服务商的话
你应该知道飞书
钉钉他们是打造了一个通用平台
然后这些服务商呢
在这个通用平台上去构建自己的产品
提供自己的服务能力对吧
他们是共建一个生态
互相合作
合作共赢
所以对于我们来讲呢
其实对于智能体来讲也是这么一个态度啊
这些大厂他们会去做通用智能体技术
他们甚至会去做这个通用的智能体平台
就像大家不知道
了解过前阵子很火的通义千问的手机客户端啊
可以点奶茶
对不对
那他既然可以点奶茶
他自然往后啊还可以做更多的事情
比如说帮我去买票
帮我去订一张演唱会的票
帮我去买一个协同的旅游的票
帮我去给谁打个电话
发个信息是吧
帮我在手机上去整理一份文件
甚至帮我去做一个短视频发出去
这些东西啊都是有想象空间的
其实在应该也是在上个月吧
上个月已经出现了一批手机智能体
对不对
但是手机智能体呢有一些问题要处理
那就是权限的问题
或者说一些敏感的这个操作的问题
手机智能体其实已经实现了
操作系统级别的智能体已经实现了
只不过说啊我拿手机智能体直接去操作你的
比如说小红书
比如说抖音等等
这些软件到底安不安全呢
或者说安全我也可以说是次要的
或者说这些厂商比如说抖音
他允许你这么做吗
其实不一定允许对吧
因为这个东西啊可能会破坏它内部的一些机制
但这个呢我们就不细讲了
那所以说这些智能体技术呢
其实呢还有很多除了这些通用平台之外
留给我们的空间是什么呢
这些通用技术我们不要我们不需要做
我们要做的就是像在启威
在这个钉钉上的这些服务商一样
我们基于这个通用智能体啊
去构建我们自己的服务
构建我们自己的智能体
比如说我举个例子啊
比如说最近未来啊
未来可能这个养老养老行业会比较发达对吧
毕竟慢慢的步入老龄化社会了
那么你是不是可以构建一个
专门为老龄化的一些人群服务的智能体对吧
他提供更专业的这个呃老年人的一些服务
当然你也可以最终啊
把它接入到这个通用自动体平台上来
所以以后你就可以结合这些通用智能体
平台的生态
一起
一起来构建你的这个垂直业务的智能体对吧
这是一个很好的一个方向
OK回吧
回到我们的这个核心的课程里面来
那我们首先要讲一个
我们之前呢也有一些公开课
大家有兴趣的话呢
都可以可以找我们的这个咨询老师去领取啊
所有的资料呢咨询老师都有
包括我们今天的课件
今天讲的这个内容呢
这个课件啊都可以找我们咨询老师去领取
好
我们回到我们今天讲的四个主题
Open cn
还有not bot
还有nt color
以及这个lobster AI是吧
我们先啊来比较一下
来比较一下这四个框架
它们之间呢到底有哪一些异同
当然我们首先得知道他们都是去也
他们做的事情啊
其实都是比较类似的对吧
都是做通用智能体领域的
注意啊
是通用智能体
不是垂直领域的智能体
这也是很多人啊
可能会对这些智能体有一些预期过高
的一些错误的认知
很多人可能会觉得
我有这么一个像open cloud这样的一个产品的好
帮我去炒股啊
帮我去呃设计一些东西啊
设计一个好的PPT
或者说帮我去呃售卖我的产品
是不是他可能想象空间很丰富
想象力很丰富
什么事情都想让这个open cloud来做
但是当你装上open cloud之后
你会发现有些东西啊他做的不是很好对吧
这就是这些人啊预期过高
或者说理解错了一个通用智能体的定位
但是不代表这些智能体啊
它没有价值
因为所有的这些通用智能体
它都会给我们提供比较好的一个扩展方式
只要你理解清楚了这些通用制动体的设计
以及找清楚了如何去拓展它
那么你就可以基于这个通用智能体啊
去做你想做的专业的事情
这个才是真正的这些通用智能体的一个呃
一个应用方式
当然像open CD这样的一些产品呢
它有一个它现在爆火呢
也给我们带来了一个非常大的一个好处啊
就是社区里面啊
有很多人在为他开发一些好用的能力
比如说最经典的就是这个open cloud呢
它是国外的一个产品
但是我们发现啊在国内你可以用飞书来介入它
对不对
这个飞书呢
就是生态里面这个开发者的一个贡献
那以后呢可能还会有很多很多的一些呃
能力集成进来
像open cloud这样的产品呢
它通常拓展点呢主要是两个部分
一个呢是插件部分
一个是scales部分
插件部分呢像我刚才说的飞书
它就是通过插件来拓展的
包括你自己呢你想去拓展一些呃
跟你的企业内部的一些数据的交流通道
交互通道
比如说我想把这个open cloud接入到我的公司里面的
某一个数据库
我想让他能够操作这个数据库
管理这个数据库对吧
那这种这种时候呢
我们通常要开发一个plugin
开发一个插件
装到我们的open cloud里面去
这是插件的一个核心能力
那skills又是做什么呢
skills呢其实就是关于垂直业务的一些方法论
关于垂直业务的各种各样的每个领域呢
可能都有它自己的一些方法论对吧
通用这种体
它本身没有什么方法论
它专门只做一些通用的事情
那如果说哎我有一套方法论啊
可以更好的跟客户交流
可以更好的维护客户关系
对不对
比如说我就是一个金牌销售
那我的销售方式啊跟别人的就不一样
我有我自己的一套方法
那这套方法呢我就可以把它给包装成skills
把这个skills装给这个open cloud
那么这个open cloud呢它就可以在需要的时候啊
去使用这套方法论
那这个时候呢它就不仅仅是做通用的事情了
他在这个销售这一块啊
马上就把以前销售的这个短板
一下子就转成了销售的一个长处对吧
所以像这一类智能体呢
它有很多丰富的这种拓展空间
那市面上大家也可以去找一找
有非常多的一些好用的Scout
甚至还有一些skills呢
它的核心目的
它设计的核心目的啊
就是为了帮你去找到一些更好的scales
所以这些人啊在这个Scout设计这一块
其实还是挺有创意的对吧
发挥的空间非常非常的大好
这节课呢我们学习目标呢大概有这么四个
大家可以看一看
第一个呢
我们要了解一下这个四个框架的核心架构
和设计理念
第二个呢我们要了解一下
通用智能体的关键技术要素有哪些核心的组件
以及我们要了解一下不同架构的这个优势
劣势和适用场景
最后呢我们再来总结一下
总总体的通用智能体的核心开发模式
这四个东西呢
其实都是为了让大家能够基于AI的能力
自己也能够去定制开发出自己的智能体来
所以我们这这节课本质的目的
就是为了让大家跟着我们的这个课程呢
一起学习一下这些东西啊
到底是怎么来设计的
你只要了解了设计方案
那么加上一个codex或者一个cloud code
你也可以自己开发出你想要的这个智能体
以及对它进行拓展
我就在今天
我甚至碰到了一个一个完全没有技术背景的人
他是竟然在使用codex在开发他自己的小程序
当然我不知道他有没有成功啊
但是这些人确实动手能力很强对吧
在这里呢其实最重要的是证明了一个点
就是你只要了解了这个东西怎么设计
你只要有自己的想法
那么你就可以具备把它落地成一个产品的能力
以前我们没有AI辅助的时候
我们经常会呃受精力的约束
比如说我作为一个后端的
我没有那么多的精力啊去学习前端
但是作为一个前端
也没有那么多精力去学习后端对吧
但是现在不一样
现在我们抛弃变成语言的差异
我们抛弃前后端或者其他的一些岗位的差异
你只要有想法
只要了解架构
只要知道这些东西怎么设计
OK你就能够干出来